nein ok meine freundin freut sich
darüber m
und was und kaufen dann ist ein viertel
von dem was ich in vier fünf jahren
youtube mehr zusammen gespart habe schon
wieder weg so ungefähr
[Musik]
hey was geht ab und herz für das ist
jetzt blöd die kamera steht leider auf
dem tisch das heißt ich muss jetzt ruhig
halten und zwacken ist auch man jetzt
hat er sich hier auf gehangen oder man
halo hey was geht ab und herzlich
willkommen bei einem neuen video der
leute ich hoffe natürlich euch geht's
gut
junge alter gut ist dass hier nicht mein
arbeitsplatz ist leute was gedacht
herzlich willkommen beim neuen video
heute haben wir was ganz besonderes vor
und zwar so eine neue einkaufs challenge
ich habe mir nämlich was bestellt habe
ich bei einem youtube angesehen die
haben so ein tracking trend ausgemacht
haben wir auf andere videos reagiert und
mir erkennt er wahrscheinlich netto
beady eye tracking nennt sich das war
ganz schön teuer also das hätte ich gar
nicht gedacht ich glaube das hat 160
euro kostet funktioniert immer
einwandfrei ich möchte damit jetzt nicht
auf irgendwelche videos reagieren ich
habe mich etwas anderes überlegen und
zwar ungefähr genau vor einem jahr habe
ich angefangen mit diesen zufällig
bestellen videos und das machen wir
heute anders wird mir webseiten
geschickt über instagram und die werde
ich mir jetzt gleich anschauen sie
öffnen und dann seht ihr immer so wo man
wo ich hinschaue also das kann man genau
sehen und ich hab mir gedacht und mal
wieder ein paar produkte vorzustellen in
weiteren videos vielleicht schon in
diesem video ich weiß noch nicht ganz
genau aber ich verspreche euch ich
bestelle wirklich alles worauf ich
schaue also wenn ich aus versehen auf
das paar schuhe schaue muss ich
bestellen das ist der sinn des videos
und ich bin will ich mal gespannt was
wir am ende des tages alles haben ob das
gehirn ist vielleicht sogar so ein
bisschen im unterbewusstsein automatisch
auf sachen schaut die man direkt als
ansprechend empfindet weil einige
menschen können das ja wenn so ein bild
erscheint dass die direkt alles war
nicht und ich sage mal so der normale
mensch kann sich ja immer dann direkt
auf eine sache fokussieren bei mir ist
das manchmal echt komisch dann sehe ich
so ein bild und denke mir so was mal war
da unten
ich eben was hast du schon mal gesehen
hast und dann gucke ich und dann stimmt
das wirklich
also es ist manchmal ganz verrückt
fangen sofort nur noch ein paar das sehr
gerne den daumen nach oben da und letzte
heute also so sieht das aus ich schaue
jetzt gerade einfach mal hier auf dass
netflix logo jetzt schaue ich auf das
youtube logo jetzt schaue ich auch zwei
die lenovo
jetzt schaue ich auf diese herrsche hier
unten
das konnte ich mich mal angucken also
man sieht ja ganz klar
es funktioniert guter fußballspieler dem
wir haben louis wahres ganz toll 3 0
gewonnen gegen caracas und wer ist das
hier
lady gaga bradley cooper was ist das
denn
ich schaue ich mich wieder an leute also
wie ihr sehen könnt
es funktioniert und jetzt sind wir eine
website nach der anderen
ich habe mir gedacht ich lasse meine uhr
laufen also ich hab immer so ungefähr
zwei minuten zeit also leute auf die
plätze fertig zwei minuten ab jetzt so
also amazon auch jetzt kann ich hier
auswählen fashion sale oder technik
geschenkideen ja dann gehen wir auf
fashion sale oder das ist wahrscheinlich
günstiger bis zu 70 prozent und mehr
zeit was und herren das würde ich so gar
nicht fax ach du scheiße crocs gar nicht
gebrauchen
ich hatte noch nie crocs komm mal gucken
was haben 21 euro bis 100 1 32 euro für
diese schule ich finde ja so und 30 also
ich hab noch nie so hässliche schuhe
gesehen
ich verstehe auch nicht ich kann auch
die leute nicht verstehen die die tragen
warte mal jetzt jetzt kann ich mir hier
auswählen den nehme ich doch dann nehme
ich das auffällig in den einkaufswagen
größe auswählen also 43 brauche ich auch
das gibt es gar nicht bis aber jetzt
schade da kommt dann nehmen wir das hier
heute wollte heute gibt's ja auch ein
günstiger ich gebe doch nicht 35 euro na
gut
ach ja was soll's
schuhe eine minute 17 8
das wird ja wieder teuer heute zwischen
25 und 30 euro
alle kategorien was kann ich denke
brauchen sport und freizeit weil ich bin
überfordert ich brauche hier von beauty
spielzeug herkommen sport und freizeit
und fußball
also eigentlich sind die zwei minuten
sofort vom freitag quelle naja wenn man
sich ok 23 mich verarschen
also das ist ja mal so ein feld neben
dem was ich heute mache jetzt nicht mehr
nehmen
okay leute wir waren an den ball noch
puls im einkaufswagen die zwei minuten
waren schon längst rum also ich denke
jetzt sollte ich alle verstanden haben
worum es geht wir machen weiter
durchgang nummer zwei auf die plätze
fertig okay die nächste website
aha jetzt muss ich aufpassen jetzt muss
ich verdammt aufpassen
also wir haben hier eine tasche da steht
jetzt hoffentlich kein preis zugenommen
also das ist jetzt die taschen kategorie
medien ihr das ist mir zu teuer
die sonnenbrille also warte mal
herren-tennis mein fehler
vorsichtig vorsichtig herren
nein okay jetzt kann ich hier nämlich
was ist denn wohl das günstigste
slippers bevor sich nicht und machen die
leute aufwecken seite bin ich denn hier
gelandet
also das ist ja mal so eine scheiße also
für 795 euro
bin ich eigentlich raus
ok ich lege die erst mal ein wort aber
ich glaube das sollte ihr verstehen dass
mir das vielleicht ein bisschen zu viel
geld ist für so etwas hässliches ich
weiß es nicht überlegt mir okay das feld
ihrem video sehen wenn ich dann die
sachen auflösung also was ich alles
bestellt hat ok sowie auf die nächste
mahlzeit auf die plätze fertig und wir
kommen zur nächsten website auf die
plätze fertig los
ok go und das ist auch okay wir haben
hier wird auch jetzt schon raus was ist
das ja okay das jetzt kann ich hier
nämlich richtig rein weil an farbe
wählen brot kaufen
ok weg der weg direkt erreicht
na das ist ja viel zu viele oder können
da kann man ja nur irgendwo drauf gucken
wollte man das hier muss ich auch noch
einmal an diese uhr war das kaufen auf
farbe wählen
orange japanisches immer gut okay wir
wollen jetzt ganz ganz langsam mal
runter ok oh oh oh oh was das denn das
wollte ich haben newsweek game konsole
händel switch probe sollte man kann man
damit wirklich spielen oder ist das nur
sind das nur diese adapter ist nur die
adapter oder der leute kann ich nichts
mit anfangen tut mir leid also wie dafür
brauche ich ja nintendos wii zweiten
stopp okay was das den home decor
waterproof ja gut nämlich nein
ok meine freundin freut sich darüber
ok t shirt ich trage was genau das passt
gut brauchen
gut also wie wir das in echt aussieht
bin ich mal gespannt
okay da war ich schon und ganz langsam
auch wie lange habe ich noch 20 sekunden
vorsichtig vorsichtig auch noch nur noch
ein t shirt okay die uhr nämlich noch
mit zac haben brauche ich noch nur ich
hab schon eine uhr ok wartet die uhr
nämlich raus dann nämlich lieber dass
die schuld ist martin obert im original
und in weiß bittl kunststoff ok alles
klar 74 euro wir haben nur wir haben
mileys vater charting fett dafür sorgen
leute ich muss an dieser stelle würde
ich sagen alles schön und gut ich würde
wirklich alles bestellen das ding ist
jetzt nur mit mit sowas kann ich nichts
anfangen und wenn ich damit nichts
anfangen kann also ich benutzt kein
samsung ist ja verschwendung soll lieber
irgendjemand anderes haben deswegen
nehmen wir das schon mal raus nur haben
ja eine vernünftige habe ich sowieso
oder nicht home depot so ein kleid ein t
shirt und noch ein t shirt das dumme ist
ja ganz klar bei diesen muss sachen das
dauert ewig bis hier ankommen deswegen
dauert auch ein bisschen für die
auflösung des video dann hiervon kommt
aber ich verspreche ich wirklich ich
bestelle das alles und werde euch das
auch alles trotzdem könnt ihr mir sehr
gerne website in die kommentare
schreiben mit denen ich das noch machen
soll eine seite haben wir nämlich noch
und die startet auch die plätze fertig
los okay da haben wir klar wider was
teil des rolex leute also da bin ich
raus wirklich also das ist ja absolut
also das wäre total dumm wenn ich mir
natürlich in diesem video nur kaufe ist
ein
wie viel von dem was ich in vier fünf
jahren youtube mehr zusammen gespart
habe schon wieder weg so ungefähr kommt
drauf an wie teuer die ist ja auf jeden
fall sehr interessant aus hier diese
weise uhr gefällt mir am rand also die
die ist echt die scheint machten
wirklich extrem guten eindruck
diese inzwischen ja besonders schön
ok jetzt gehen wir noch mal langsam hier
nach oben jetzt müssen wir erst mal den
text lesen schauen sie sich die rolle
des professionellen modelle an und
finden sie ihr lieblingsmodell indem sie
material ja wirklich so interessant ich
glaube einige nette produkte sind
zusammengekommen ist wirklich recht
anstrengend für mich so also wenn man
die ganze zeit sieht wo man hinguckt
irgendwie strengt mich das an trotzdem
ist ganz lustig also eure aufgabe hat
mir gesagt mach das doch mal öfter keine
ahnung ich könnte auch mal so zum
beispiel mein essen zusammenstellen das
wäre ja auch mal lustig dann gebt doch
nach oben und dann nochmal das mal ist
auf jeden fall ein cooles produkt für
diese trecker und wir sehen uns morgen
oder übermorgen wieder gibt es neues
video
ich gehe jetzt erstmal ein bisschen
karneval feiern und das was von mir
haut rein freut sich auf die
produktvideos gab es jetzt länger nicht
und danke auch an meinem bruder dass ich
hier sein windows pc benutzen darf